impossible de la manquer en sortant de
la gare de versailles rive gauche
cette station de location de
trottinettes et la première et unique du
département à l'origine de ce projet
deux yvelinois qui ont parié sur ce
service pratique et écolo le principe
est simple il va vous avez téléchargé
l'application android je me mets
libération trottinette je choisis
ensuite en parallèle vous avez un casier
qui s'est ouvert sur le côté dans lequel
je pouvoir retirer un casque et un
cadenas qui sont dans un petit sac et je
pars chao en une ce sont en fait de
mobilité complémentaires qui vient
s'additionner aux transports publics
existants ou transport privé qui vit qui
n'est pas concurrent du vélo puisque
chacun choisit son mode de transport
mais il contribue effectivement à
fluidifier la circulation et améliorer
les choses
l'ambition de cette start up qui cultive
son identité yvelinoise c'est de
s'implanter dans tout le département
nous sommes société complètement
yvelinoise on y voit là puisque notre
siège est à versailles et on espère
d'ailleurs que toutes les collectivités
vont nous aider dans cette démarche là à
saint quentin en yvelines dans un
premier temps on a rationnement 2 points
2 essais de tests c'est à dire qu'on
fera un premier test de la gare de
saint-quentin justement une zone
d'activité qui sera peut-être celle du
parc ariane et la deuxième demande de 50
ans on y vivre c'est d'étudier justement
la zone en fait de plaisir les
clayes-sous-bois avec toute la nouvelle
zone commerciale qui existe les deux
fondateurs qui ont parié toutes leurs
économies dans ce projet misent sur une
centaine de stations d'ici un an